olá é um prazer imenso tá aqui hoje
ocupando esse espaço enquanto mulher
enquanto mulher negra e essa música
chama-se lua ferida de tantos espaços
que a gente não consegue transitar
enquanto pessoa preta enquanto a mulher
preta enquanto a mulher é tem espaços
que eu consigo apesar de tudo me dizer
que lugar nenhum é o meu lugar
oi e essa música é o inter cruzamento de
dois desses lugares que são a arte e
astrofísica que são dois lugares que
profissionalmente e o trânsito é agora
mais a música né mas trabalhei bastante
com astrofísica e essa música fala sobre
isso por isso diz lua ferida é porque as
crateras da lua são frutas de impacto
das então a maioria delas são sim
cicatrizes então eu peço que a lua que é
toda ferida me ensine a fazer beleza das
marcas de dor e tristeza deixadas pelas
pedras que a vida atirou
o e nisso de trabalhar obrigada
[Música]
bom obrigada missa de trabalhar também
com astrofísica muitos e p cílios foram
colocados no meu caminho muitas coisas
me disseram que ali não era meu lugar
que a ciência não é o lugar da mulher
preta
bom e isso começa desde que a gente
chega na sala de aula e olha em volta e
não se ver quando a gente olha o corpo
docente ea gente não tá se lecionando
hoje a gente está trabalhando na
manutenção do espaço e sendo podado de
fazer qualquer coisa que nos conecte com
a dignidade então é muito bom usufruir
desse espaço ocupar esse espaço estar
presente nesse espaço e trazer a ciência
como assunto como um start também para
que sigam para que mulheres pretas sigam
fazendo aquilo que elas querem seja lá o
que for e que por mais difícil que seja
todos os lugares são o nosso lugar por
mais que toda a estrutura tente nos
colocar para fora a gente precisa ocupar
esses espaços
e quando aria
e conseguia
o koch que ela a boca
e a tia mão gula mexer a passar
semicírculo nunca
me convide aquela mulher marcha
e na boca
e aí
oi haha
oi haha make it in
olá a todos esses dani saiba eu sou
jovem sofreu 16 sexy fosse aqui eles aí
essa semana raquel ciara oh
o ninja que disseram que o que é eu
quero ficar sem a parede um brinquedo
pensar you tudo servir a barbie fica
tudo sabe ser razão para celebrar mesmo
quando se está só não fazem beleza e
e tirou tu tanto tudo tudo tudo tudo
[Música]
porque tá difícil tudo sabe ser razão
para ser lembrado mesmo quando se está
só espero já está perto de saber
transformar a
me ajudou e tristeza de deus que habita
[Música]
em
o que sozinha me faz sentir na estrada
porque a vida criou um
[Música]
oi boa tarde
é muito obrigada
é muito obrigada e